I occasionally tape segments around town
with our shows associate producer Jordan
shlonsky there's a photo of him trying
to hypnotize ya people into sleeping
with him well tonight I'm excited to
announce that our industrious digital
artists at Team Coco have created
something called that Jordan shlonsky
various quotes and phrases generator
it's amazing it's a new feature on Team
Coco comm where you can listen to some
of Jordan's most memorable and
irritating quotes from over the years
and it's a special bonus you can have
fun with his cold dead expressionless
eyes here's just a small example I'm a
deeply emotional man I have various
duties my title is associate producer
twice a week I shave remove excess hair
I shave other areas I wake up I have
cappuccino and a savory pastry
[Applause]
is all real thing saving a school
because are real things that horrible
man has said check out the Georgian
slansky furious quotes in phrases
generator at shlonsky generator calm
it's better than doing any work at the
office when you think about it hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great cone
and clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography